and you have been watching pictures
there are people in Baghdad stuff real
square celebrating the killing of senior
Iranian commander Qasem Soleimani by US
forces I'm Stan grant here in Doha of
course taking over this breaking
coverage live coverage of this strike by
American forces inside Iraq now we've
had information now confirmation from
the Pentagon that US President Donald
Strunk Donald Trump had ordered this
strike inside Iraq that has killed a
commander of Iran's elite hoods force
now he was killed in the strike just
next to the city's airport the Kurds
force is responsible for Iran's overseas
and clandestine military operations now
also killed was Araki militia commander
Abu Mukhtiar Mohandas he was the deputy
leader of Iraq's hushed shabi militia
the Pentagon as I was saying has
confirmed now the death of Soleimani in
its statement it says it was done on the
orders of the u.s. president the killing
has also been confirmed by Iranian state
TV and for that we go to Georgia Murray
who's joins us on the phone from Tehran
door sir is there no we seem to have
lost door sir we'll go to the United
States where Gabrielle Elizondo is
standing by Gabrielle can you tell us
more about what the US has confirmed
here where the Pentagon has confirmed
here with this strike yeah it was a
pretty remarkable Department of Defense
statement about this it's good two and a
half paragraphs long I won't read the
entire thing again but the key points
that stand out in here is obviously the
United States Department of Defense
confirming that the strike that killed
Soleimani was at the direction of the
President of the United States that
should not necessarily be a surprise
given the the high profile of Soleimani
but also in the statement of by the
Department of Defense they really
pointed out how soleimani in their view
was actively planning more attacks on
Americans and American diplomats in the
region there was a real sense in this
statement that soleimani and his cuts
or a an immediate threat to American
lives in the region
I'll read part of it general Soleimani
was actively developing plans to attack
American diplomats and servicemembers in
Iraq and throughout the region general
Soleimani and his cuts force were
responsible for the death of hundreds of
American and coalition servicemembers
and the wounding of thousands more again
that's two sentences from the statement
just confirmed by the Department of
Defense here it's important to point out
that beyond this statement we have not
heard anything officially from the White
House or the President of the United
States he did tweet a picture of the
American flag but beyond that no
official statement from the president
Donald Trump he's at his mar-a-lago
resort still in the middle of a vacation
there also nothing from the State
Department either but clearly this is a
major major strike by the Department of
Defense clearly it was at the direction
of the president who of course is the
commander-in-chief and would be giving
the direction in in in this case Gabriel
I want you to stay there and I'll be
going to Dorsett Jabari in Iran in just
a moment for the reaction from there but
let's place this into context as well
because we had seen in recent days those
protests inside Iraq in Baghdad
protesters linked to the popular
mobilization forces that militia linked
to Iran who marched directly to the
American Embassy set fire to the area
had dogged the area with graffiti had
been chanting anti-american slogans so
placed this into a broader context of
what we've seen in recent days the
American strikes the protests and now
this action we've seen carried out today
yeah for sure those protests that
reached the doors of the US Embassy
shook Washington there's no doubt about
that this was a protesters Iranian
linked militia that got through a
heavily fortified Green Zone and got
through multiple layer
of checkpoints and multiple layers of
security to get right up to the door of
the most heavily guarded and biggest and
you might even say most important US
diplomatic mission in the entire world
and that's the US Embassy in Baghdad
that shook the Pentagon I think it shook
the State Department and I think it
shook the White House as well and I
think what you're seeing here is a
reaction to that there was a clear
understanding I think over the last few
days since this is all transpired that
the u.s. had the option of striking
there were probably multiple options
presented to President Donald Trump and
he clearly went with the most severe one
this is you can't put this or or
overstate this enough it should be
pointed out that over the past ten years
or so Iran excuse me Israel has
reportedly had Soleimani in their
crosshairs and and we're going to strike
him but in both cases President Obama at
the time and president george w bush
convinced the israelis not to because
killing him could potentially set up
incredible ramifications now he has been
killed there was a different choice that
was made by President Donald Trump so
the u.s. just to summarize here the US
this week has sent 750 paratroopers to
the region to buffer security they have
several thousand more troops on standby
for deployment we've reached out to Fort
Bragg and CENTCOM to see if any more
troops are being deployed to the region
and so far no response on that yet but
clearly without a doubt this is a major
escalation we'll have to hear from the
president what he has to say about this
presumably when he announces more about
this decision in did Gabriel thank you
for that and of course we'll come back
to you for any further developments from
the United States
let's cross now to Dawson Jabari who's
joins us on the phone from Tehran
we're just listening to Gabriel Elizondo
their daughter who is now confirming of
course that the Pentagon has said that
this strike was carried out under the
orders of President Trump and also
accusing Qasem Soleimani of planning
on American diplomats an American
service personnel before we get to the
detail of that for those who are just
joining us now take us back a step and
tell us who Qasem Soleimani was his role
in the Iranian military and his
significance within the Iranian regime
certainly a scintilla nominee at the
head of the horse force which is the
branch within the Revolutionary Guard
that filled with external missions
outside of Iran
so their charge cast with foreign
missions so they deal with their own
foreign policy when it comes to military
outside of the country now he was
appointed by the supreme leader
Ayatollah Ali Khamenei as the head of
the course at some point in the early
90s we're not exactly sure when his
appointment took place but he was fought
in the iran-iraq war and then he was
part of the Revolutionary Guards in the
province for many years and he rose up
the ranks very quickly and he's one of
the who was one of the closest
confidants and allies and friends of the
Supreme Leader he was awarded a the
highest medal of honor by the
commander-in-chief Ayatollah Khamenei
just last year for his services that
means they're conducted on behalf of
Iran he is known as a very reclusive
figure inside the country there are
tales about him of people who met him
just coming into the office this morning
I was speaking to the security guards at
my building the taxi driver he is his
name synonymous with Iranian national
pride no matter what he's been labeled
outside the country
no man inside Iraq matter which side you
lean on politically essentially money or
Hajj cause him as he's known is a figure
who resonates with Iranians as somebody
who has had the best interest of Iran at
heart to see he has been instrumental in
preventing ISIL from setting sport on
Iranian soil over the past few years
when I was speaking to my taxi driver we
were listening to say radio on on the
way in there is already songs of morning
the announcer saying that it is with
great sadness that we announce the
martyrdom of Qasem Soleimani in Iraq and
condolences to all of the Iranian people
in the nation the taxi driver was so
shocked he could barely speak and how to
actually pull over and take a minute
before he could continue his ride and he
said that this is something that they
never people never believed could happen
because there is a or of mystery and
grandiose about often soleimani that
people spoke about so now that this news
of his death as a fascination there is a
tremendous amount of shock and anger
that would follow in the next few hours
that we will see not only in Iran but
across the Middle East he was
instrumental in Iran's policies in
Lebanon his close relationship with
Hassan Nutella
Hezbollah in Lebanon is well documented
that to have had numerous occasions
where they didn't photograph together
alongside the Supreme Leader his
relationship with other eyes feather the
feather family in Iraq is also
noteworthy he has spent a lot of time in
the holy city of Najaf so he is very
well known across the region both within
the political rounds and the military
circles of the region he is somebody who
is also known to be very kind very
humble was I should say hmm I had heard
stories of people who were on plane
rides that he was on and he spent the
entire time speaking to people about his
experiences about his movements he comes
from very humble backgrounds in Canada
province and he is somebody who is not
new to
the danger of his life in within his
life we have had many assassination
attempt carried out and failed and there
was also an attack even within Iran
there was an attempt on his life just
last year they was a the intelligence
ministry and we Revolutionary Guards
released a statement saying that big
four have been attack the bombing of a
mosque which he attends in his hometown
and that there were people there was a
network of people that were behind the
attempted assassination they purchased
property near the mosque where he goes
for service whenever he's in his
hometown they were trying baby found
explosives in the basement of this
mosque
so he's not somebody who needed to the
dangers of his life and his jobs and
this you know their supreme leader spoke
yesterday saying it specifically
responded to Donald Trump tweeting about
Iran and the attacks in Iraq and the
latest developments there the supreme
leader said that that's man's and tweets
does attend not do a damn thing and now
this has happened that in the direct
retaliation really to what the supreme
leader had tweeted on Wednesday it is
likely to have far-reaching consequences
I mean Qasem Soleimani is just beyond a
well-known figure in Iran dorsa thank
you of course your stay on the line
because we're coming back to you
periodically to get the latest from
there particularly if there's anything
official coming out of Iran
we'll get back to Gabriel Elizondo now
in Washington DC
Gabriel you're hearing more about
response from inside the United States
to this strike and the killing of Qasem
Soleimani a little bit more we still
haven't heard from the President of the
United States we still haven't heard
from Secretary of State Mike Pompeo and
we still have not heard from the
Secretary of Defense mr. Esper
so we're having to rely on information
from the highest ranking government
officials that are speaking about this
and another one just tweeted that would
be Senator Lindsey Graham a Republican
and a very very close ally of the
president Donald Trump in fact
Lindsey Graham was just in mar-a-lago
with the president and he actually might
still be that with the president he just
tweeted and I want to read you what he
said this is from Lindsey Graham the US
Senator Wow the price of killing and
injuring Americans has just gone up
drastically major blow to Iranian regime
that has American blood on its hands
soleimani was one of the most ruthless
and vicious members of the ayatollahs
regime he had American blood on his
hands
I appreciate President Donald Trump's
bold action against Iranian aggression
to the Iranian government I say if you
want more you will get more so this kind
of summarizes a little bit of one side
of what we're hearing from some
lawmakers that are sort of if you will
taking a victory lap applauding Donald
Trump for this for this strike but we're
also seeing others in Washington on
Twitter and elsewhere also really
worried about how this could escalate
and what comes next but clearly you're
seeing there from Senator Lindsey Graham
sort of a victory if you will at least
the way he sees this Thank You Gabrielle
of course you'll stay with us as well
just to bring you up-to-date if you are
just joining us we are discussing the
strike by US forces confirmed now by the
Pentagon ardent on the orders of
President Trump inside Iraq which has
killed a senior figure in the Iranian
regime Qasem Soleimani the man who was
the commander of Iran's elite could
forces also killed was Iraqi militia
leader Abu Abu Mukti al Mohandas who is
linked to militia inside Iraq and of
course he's linked also to Iran let's go
to Baghdad now some other 14 he's going
to join us live from there and there has
always already been a response on the
streets among people who have been out
there celebrating indeed the death of
Qasem Soleimani tell us more about that
indeed well the people who are in
Baghdad Tahrir Square of course these
are anti-government protesters who have
been
camping out there for months now to
protest against the government but also
against Iranian influence in Iraq and
the people have been basically camping
out there so they were already present
when this strike took place and what
we've been seeing is them celebrating in
the square basically welcoming the death
of Qasem Soleimani and a bomb a steel
Mohandas both of whom are seen as
basically the embodiment of iranian
influence in the country now of course
these protesters have nothing to do with
the crowds that we have seen march on
the US embassy a couple of days ago
those were crowd of the popular
mobilization forces which is this
paramilitary group that is basically
very closely linked to Iran and Abu
mafia Mohammed this was the second in
charge of that group work likely to see
a very different reaction from from that
side it remains to be seen what exactly
it will be but many people here in
Baghdad are fearing that there will be
retaliation that there will be
escalation with the members and
supporters of the popular mobilization
forces reacting to the deaths of their
main leaders basically and this could be
perhaps through additional
demonstrations this could be another
attempt to once again storm the US
Embassy or perhaps we're likely to see
additional rocket attacks on bases and
locations where US personnel are based
which we have been seeing quite a few of
over the past few months but what is
very important is that there will be
very different reactions the majority of
Iraqis are likely to welcome this
because they have basically disapproved
of Iranian influence in the country but
then we're likely to see a very
different reaction from the popular
mobilization forces
yeah and Simona are you learning
anything more about why Qasem Soleimani
was indeed inside the country there has
been some speculation that he was there
to oversee this political transition
this political vacuum that has appeared
inside Iraq now particularly the recent
nomination for prime minister of someone
very much linked to Iran are you hearing
anything more about that well Qasem
Soleimani has been a frequent visitor to
baghdad not just now but on many
previous occasions and especially during
the past three months of anti-government
protests he was actually seen as being
somebody who was leading in a way the
government's response and crackdown on
these protests by basically creating
special security cells to target
demonstrators through either
assassinations for snipers for
kidnappings so he somebody's seen as
basically coming in and out of Baghdad
as he pleases and as somebody who has
had a vast amount of influence over the
Iraqi government many Iraqis feel that
the Prime Minister has not been the one
who has been really in charge of this
government and it is figures like Qasem
Soleimani
who have actually been running the show
so his presence in Baghdad is by no
means surprising it has been something
that has been happening for a long time
Samanta thank you so much for that and
of course we'll come back to you as we
continue to follow this breaking news we
want to take you now to Lawrence Korb
there was a former us Assistant
Secretary of Defense and he joins us via
Skype from Washington DC nice to have
you with us as well we've been
discussing the significance of Qasem
Soleimani clearly someone who cast an
enormous shadow and was linked at the
highest level in Iran a close personal
confidant of the Ayatollah Khamenei so
how do you now assess his death and the
implications from this well I think the
implications are very strong for the
United States saying given what you've
done here you know why killing and
killing an American and wounding several
others we are going to make you pay a
price and I think what happened was this
was a target of opportunity
I don't know how long Solomon's visit
was planned but what would the events
over the weekend the demonstrations
against the American Embassy and then
knowing that he was coming I think that
the United States decided this is how we
can send a very strong message without
killing very many people will kill the
to leave you the two leaders
that will send the send a message and
and as I mentioned earlier three hours
before this Secretary of Defense s purse
said you know we're going to take action
preemptive action to make sure nothing
like this happens again we don't know if
Salah Manning was planning more attacks
or anything but the fact of the matter
is this sense of a signal I think to
Iran you know don't go any further we
don't want any more American troops till
and I think they convinced President
Trump to do it because he does not want
to see this get out of hand and I think
people said if you do this that will
send a very strong messaging maybe this
these killings will stop
is it a strong enough message though
that Iran will not retaliate
particularly retaliate through its
proxies its militia proxies inside Iraq
and that we don't see a further
escalation is that not the risk here
well there's certainly a risk I mean
when you do something you know like we
did that in fact there was a risk once
we had the attack where we killed the
you know 24 25 Iraqis who out of the
popular mobilization in front and
wounded several others there was a risk
you know when when that happened but the
fact of the matter is that right now the
ball is in a Rance Court and I don't
think that they wanted all-out fight
with the United States they will
probably as we discussed earlier maybe
we do some asymmetric type of attacks
where they would cause more problems
throughout the Valkyr region whether
it's in Syria or Lebanon and but
basically I think they're the ones that
gonna have to make the decision because
if they want to get into an all-out war
with the United States on logic on a
conflict that's not going to benefit
them given you know the economic
problems that that they have there is of
course an alternative to all-out
conflict with the United States and
his continues to try to wear America
down and making the united states
increasingly unpopular in Iraq get
America out of Iraq and we've even seen
with protesters who have been anti-iran
or anti the Iraqi government and not
necessarily pro the United States is
that not also a potential consequence of
this testing the resolve of the United
States and America's future inside Iraq
yeah there's no doubt about the fact
that the Iraqi Parliament's gonna vote
it's going to be interesting to see what
this event does in terms of the the both
the second largest bloc in the iraqi
parliament is a pro-iranian full iranian
group and if they would vote and this
the united states to leave obviously we
would have to and I think the Iranian
government is not happy because we had
the other attack without coordinating
with them it's going to be interesting
to see if secretary Pompeo called the
Prime Minister Abadi before he you know
before you did this like he did it
though the last time we haven't heard
anything about that yet but I think
that's going to be interesting and you
know it's also interesting in fact this
must have been you know coming up
because Pompeo cancelled his trip do you
to stay there so he must have known they
must have had intelligence about Solomon
incoming and they decided to take action
Lawrence Korb thank you so much and
hopefully we'll get to speak to you
again as this story continues to develop
Lawrence Korb they're joining us from
the US via Skype and of course we are
continuing our breaking news coverage of
this news out of Iraq that the United
States has carried out a strike on the
orders of President Trump that has
targeted significant figures within the
Iraqi militia and also the Iranian
military including Qasem Soleimani a
Major General in the Islamic
Revolutionary Guard Corps and the
commander of the elite hoods force we go
back to the United States now where
Gabriel Elizondo is standing by in
Washington to you DC and Gabriel you've
been following the response and there
has been tweeted tweets sent out by
various men
of government politicians and so on
what's the latest you can give us from
there yeah I want to give you the latest
so we just got a statement here that
just came in to us this comes from the
chairman of the Senate Foreign Relations
Committee
this is Senator Jim Rice this is
important because he kind of summarizes
what the feeling is of most Republican
lawmakers here in Washington right now
is and that's congratulations to the
president Donald Trump in fact he starts
the statement by saying congratulations
to President Trump on his decisive
action and the successful outcome of
this operation he goes on to say how
sulamani was responsible for the deaths
of Americans and that's why he was
targeted he finishes his statement by
saying on behalf of every American
service member and service woman who
have either been killed or injured due
to an Iranian provided AED or rocket in
Iraq over the years today justice was
done Soleimani was responsible for the
weapons program that caused those
casualties and injured injuries with
those who use those treacherous and
cowardly devices again we're talking
about this senator here because we have
not heard directly from the president
United States yet we have not heard from
the Secretary of State Mike Pompeo or
the leader of the Department of Defense
Secretary of Defense either and so we're
having to rely on the statements now
from the highest-ranking lawmakers
reacting to this and I think this really
summarizes what we've seen from others
such as Lindsey Graham as well really a
victory if you will is sort of the is
what were the sense we're getting from
lawmakers in Washington here this
evening
Gabrielle thank you for that